die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen tragen im
hintergrund dazu bei
maria cardoso ist straßen prozent
das spanische roll ist postauto
chauffeur
regula fankhauser ist sanitäterin und
marcel blum ist tcs patrouille
wie leben diese menschen wofür setzen
sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt vier menschen und
ihr alltag ein tag im leben der schweiz
august zürich morgen zum 4 maria hat
frühschicht
ganzes riskiert mehr
halb fünf im unter einer die ein tag wie
jeder an acht millionen menschen stehen
am morgen auf caspar gehört zu den
frühaufstehern kann den schlaf
maria ist portugiesin sie kamen die
schweiz und geld zu verdienen und hat
glück gehabt
ist wie eine kinder mit einer go kart
oder ich mach das bitte
marcel hingegen ist in der innerschweiz
geboren und träumt von der großen weiten
welt
und regina hat im berner gürbetal ihr
paradies gefunden
zusammen mit ihrem mann betreibt sie
einen bauern betrieb mit 32 mio
das paar hat drei buben wird ist erstes
nummer eins drauf ist macht muss
autokraten und gehe hatte die spitze
es ist halb sechs caspar ist 63
er hat schon immer im unterengadin
gelebt den sommer verbringt der postauto
chauffeur am liebsten auf seinem einsatz
bei seinen ersten praktisch war ihnen
meinst du bist krönt und die regel sind
ja regime und denen nun modell felix und
julia gehören ihm acht weitere esel
hütete er im sommer dazu
da sind sowie aber auch sie mit mir sind
genau machen
im kanton luzern tcs patrouille marcel
hat kinder dienst heute morgen seine
frau musste schon früh los
fabio ist elfter und nico 7
nico ist oft nervös
mayele das neueste familienmitglied soll
helfen ihn zur ruhe zu bringen
regulär ist auf dem weg nach bern sie
arbeitet 50 im notfall team der
sanitätspolizei
das
das macht
macht bleiben
das ist organisierte sie war eine der
ersten frauen die hier teilzeit arbeiten
konnte es ist kurz vor 7
in zürich sorgen 190 leute mit 50 kleine
putzwagen für saubere straßen
maria macht die niederdorf tour mit
ihrem ehemann mario zusammen
die beiden sind ein eingespieltes team
bisher ist max i
mai reuters one
seitlich linken sind 28 jahren den
lieferanten
wir haben immer zusammengehalten
naja hat war meine frau kommt die arbeit
immer an erster stelle
auf dem 1
seit 15 jahren ist das paar mit doris
liniert zusammen betreiben sie im sommer
eine beige bites waschbar ist im ganzen
tal bekannt
das postauto dienst beginnt um viertel
nach acht in flammen das ist fünf
kilometer weit entfernt
die sanitäts notrufzentrale in band für
regula geht's los
eine frau hat hunde medikamente
geschluckt und ist nicht mehr
ansprechbar
das notfallteam ist zu dritt unterwegs
regula ihr kollege mike und die junge
ärztin die mit
eine freundin hatte die frau in die
arztpraxis gebracht
das notfallteam weiß nicht welche und
wie viele medikamente sie geschluckt hat
bei den zu spät
der werkhof der zürcher stadtreinigung
zum zweiten mal pause maria arbeitet
seit sechs stunden
maria ist die einzige frau in dieser
männerwelt der kollegen kommen vor allem
aus portugal und aus dem kosovo
insgesamt arbeiten menschen aus 13
nationen ihren in der innerschweiz htcs
petroleum hsl in den ersten zwei stunden
schon zwei batterien gewechselt
das ist die häufigste pannenursache
macht was probieren
der tcs hat 15 millionen mitglieder und
leistet etwa 300.000 panneneinsätze pro
jahr
es ist 10
nicht immer wird marcel so freundlich
empfangen
natürlich auch lieder und sämtliche
sturm quartett ist oder sich wirklich
schlimmes im durchstehen unter sich
natürlich an haupt- und erwartet dass
meine show berauschend eingeholt
seit jahren mit jetzt endlich ruhiger
vertreter der provinz in einer
notsituation sind im berner inselspital
die patientin ist stabil muss aber zur
beobachtung bleiben
offenbar hat sie die tabletten ihre
beiden hunde versehentlich geschluckt
bei medikamenten einnahmen müssen regula
und ihre kollegen immer befürchten dass
es ein suizid versuch war
if you're talking machen
marias job wird anstrengend sobald sich
die stadt zürich bevölkert
zumal ein kommt ihr zu wohnen an
verlinken
reuter das ist schon jetzt im stress
da muss ich
ganz konzentriert sich jetzt
wenn ich wieder aufwache den maschinen
jetzt muss polen konzentration
heute morgen gesagt es ist
kinder wie go kart von aber jetzt
brauche schon die konzentration dass sie
keine keine fehler machen
dichte stress hat das paar nicht
seine gäste sind wanderer und
dorfbewohner erfährt die drei kilometer
strecke clara mosch und zurück jeden
morgen fünf mal
der gelernte maurer arbeitet schon seit
44 jahren teilzeit bei der post
trotz einer durch straßen mit den
ausstellern und faris immer dreimal am
tag
morgen mittag und mobilheime über die
gleiche strecke genau das wird nicht
langweilig
und mit der bosch muss er das postauto
von spuren abfahrt dann geht es wieder
hinauf
in der sanitätspolizei bleibt zeit für
einen kaffee 18 leute leisten hier im
schnitt 46 einsätze pro tag
aber es gibt auch schwierige situationen
längerfristig der beruf aber der cup
teams oder dabei sogar profis
aber das glaube dass mit einem schlag
die isa probieren in schubladen stuhl
die schublade zu tun
in viele motorradfahrer wurde wo der
unfall passiert ist autor und es mir
ansehen der unter die haut geht aber ich
hasse mitte zu tun
es ist halb eins dieses kebab restaurant
in luzern ist mars ins fixpunkt jeden
tag
hier kriegt er immer das gleiche menü
für 20 franken
abgesehen von den kundenkontakten haben
tcs mitarbeiter einen einsamen
arbeitstag
marcel ist in einer achtköpfigen familie
aufgewachsen trugen hatte er früher im
überfluss jetzt genießt er es wenn er
mal ruhe
familien und
an einem normalen tag kommen in zürichs
innenstadt etwa 30 tonnen abfall
zusammen
maria lehrt ihren putzwagen zum dritten
und letzten mal fertig für heute
viele schweizer würden diesen job nicht
freiwillig machen
da denke ich nicht dass ich macht die
treppe von der schweiz auf keinen fall
das nicht ich könnte in der coop weiter
arbeite ich war in der woche
ich war in größeren team also ich bin
gekommen weil ich selber bin ich im
moment
ich bin kein hat möchte pistole gesagt
du musst das machen aber sonst musst du
verschwinden
auch caspar ist fertig mit seinem dienst
knapp 70 einwohner viele junge leute
ziehen in die stadt
ich bin so cool sexy oder aber eben über
leitung jetzt in zürich blieb und so das
sieht man ihr so überzeugt meine kinder
richtig 2000
manchmal ist es aber auch ein nachteil
wenn jeder jeden kennt
ja
mit seiner ersten familie hatte gasparin
flagge wohnt dass er nun mit seiner
neuen partnerin doris oben im einzel
sind bilder er liebt wurde schon bemerkt
im unterland herrscht hektik das ist
rigoros achter einsatz heute jemand mist
etwas in die luftröhre geraten
probleme etwas datenbank verstopft ist
das geld ist
der vorfall hat sich in einem großen
einkaufszentrum ereignet das team muss
schauen wie es möglichst schnell zum
patienten kommt
dieser mann hat sich im restaurant an
einem fly stück verschluckt er kann
nicht mehr gut atmen das fleisch stück
ist zu weit runter gerutscht
möglich seien
gut
richtig froh
glück gehabt ausgeliehen
auf gut deutsch einige bootshaus machen
es ist 3 marcel ist schon seit zwölf
jahren beim tcs auf dem weg zu seinen
kunden bleibt manchmal zeit um
schwedisch zu lernen
sein traum wäre auszuwandern
guten tag können sie uns zu den
verfahren
haye kann die scheibe aus dem store was
natürlich schwerer schön ist die wiki
oder mehr wiegt als der der dichte
stress romero interpret alles ist sauber
430 franken usa mit 8 rops schwung sehr
schön süß metall suite ablegen also
sicher für machbar
männer oder schweiz was mit einem roten
riesen abgeholt und außen schon wahnsinn
normale bitter wenig das böse an ihrem
platz leiste mit den russen sich gerade
machbar
jasper würde eigentlich bald pensioniert
aber davon will er nichts wissen
wenig später vor annika höflich schon
hobbyfahrer warum einfach mit der ybbs
und bitten kontakt so nah vor kurzem
hatte ein neues hüftgelenk bekommen
deshalb muss doris das meiste alleine
machen nur beim aufräumen hilft caspar
mit
maria und mario haben feierabend
der schrebergarten in zürichs
aussenquartier seebach ist ihr paradies
einer von 150000 schrebergarten in der
schweiz hier verbringen die beiden ihre
gesamte freizeit hier fühlen sie sich
wohl
maria und mario sind kinderlos geblieben
das war nicht so geplant als sie in die
schweiz kamen hatten sie es sony status
und mussten die familienplanung
verschieben
ich kenne eine barwasser die kinder
nachher drei monate ganz allein
gelassenen familie die mutter und vater
sind da gekommen und hat ein baby mit
drei monate allein gelassen
das sind viel oder dann hast du dich
kinder nachher wenn die kinder schon ein
bisschen größer dass sie nicht schreien
was wir sagen könnte ich dann sind die
schranke versteckt dass niemand merkt
dass die kinder alter ist weil das war
verboten
ihr könnt ihr keine krankenkasse mache
für die kinder wir können ethik in einer
schule schicken verbot gewehrt
maria das wort kinder oder schweiz
alles wegnehmen und dann wieso das aber
jetzt schon nicht mehr ihre liebe
jedenfalls hat das alles überstanden
beschichtet
es ist 5 genießt seine zweite liebe die
besen bartz war sein großer traum aber
es ist nicht nur einfach möglichkeit zum
summen zusammen da kann ich so willst du
ich bin recht bundes und gefangen und
ein bisschen ganz optimal haben sie ihre
leben noch nicht aufeinander abgestimmt
zumindest aus der sicht von toris serie
das so meint jetzt eigentlich sieht dich
dhabi hat sich alles um die arbeit geht
und ich meine und viele moleküle mag und
was ich stand oder was machen wir dann
finde ich brauche einfach ein drama und
erlebnis wo ihm verbindet und und wenn
es nur die optische stinkt mir
da will ich nicht wieder gas
natalie und jetzt kommt ruhe
in seftigen im berner gürbetal wartet
eine bauernfamilie auf die mutter
regulars dienst ist zu ende
die buben haben ferien und helfen dem
vater bei der arbeit im stall
sich wohl
regula muss noch das heil einholen
sie möchten nirgends anders leben
politischer wirtschaftlicher stabilität
mit einem grandiosen landschaftsbild
privileg schützen zusammen
bei cardosos wird gegrillt spanische
freunde sind zu besuch
maria bedeutet die familie alles sie
leidet darunter dass alle so weit
voneinander weg sind ihre mutter lebt in
portugal ihre beiden brüder in genf und
davos
aber wenn eine gut geht dann nicht geht
auch nicht gut
das wäre wunderschön wenn zumindest er
was in davos der ganz allein in der
russisch wenn er da in zürich wäre dann
wäre wirklich ein traum das wäre mein
traum
das wäre ein traum dass er natürlich
kommt das tut mich weder als er ganz
alleine dort ist dann wäre das ganz
anderes im luzernischen schachen ist
doch marcel fertig mit der natur
o
die blues haben möchten einen jungen
hund was als frau miriam ist daran im
parterre einen hundesalon einzurichten
miriam hat bisher auswärts gearbeitet
nun möchte sie wegen der kinder zu hause
geld verdienen
auch der haushaltskasse das gut marcel
trank immer noch seinen traum vom
auswandern nach schweden seine familie
versteht zwar seinen wunsch aber
begeistert ist sie nicht und ich glaube
wenn ich mir das muss wenn das auch für
nicht erhöht
das projekt schweden wird marcel noch
einiges an überzeugungsarbeit kosten
auch auf regulars bauernhof gibt es
nachts jannis hat für die ganze familie
omelett gekocht sein zwillingsbruder
schule hilft mit
andrin der kleinste hat hunger
der starb als junge familie war
schwierig die beiden zwillinge kam drei
monate zu früh zur welt
es war lange nicht klar ob sie überleben
würden
aber diese schweren zeiten sind vorbei
nun ist es die wirtschaftliche situation
die ihnen manchmal sorgen macht
karlsruhe im frühling ist sie mit einem
jahr mit dem priester stark zu machen
verschiedene szenarien was ausgerichtet
ist dass das willst du mir fiel auf dass
ich fünf jahre als physisch einfach die
kombination eines vorsieht
ich glaube dass das passiert ist
rees wir nicht klagen und bringt
lehrling ried zum zug
nachher muss erweitern eine
infoveranstaltung der gemeinde
im unteregger die ihnen genießen
touristen abend
sie verbindet die ruhe hier und das
einfache leben in der natur
als zufrieden anstatt nur dass er nicht
mehr alles machen kann was er will
moment gar nicht irgendwie dass man den
plötzlich ausgeschrieben aber zu
schultert die idee und was man alles weg
mache ich mich deutlich schwieriger das
mitdenken muss man auch wissen
es ist 8 auch wenn es draußen noch hell
ist
maria und mario müssen ins bett morgen
früh um 2 geht es wieder los
aber maria mack sich nicht beklagen ich
bin zufrieden mit wasser reinigt wenn
ich weiter so frieder bin verwundert
nicht
noch ein bisschen portugiesisches
fernsehen für mario
die chance
maria bevorzugt das internet für mädchen
die nachrichten dampf aus dass träsch
dass politik politik politik politik und
das recht mich weil es ändert nichts
sehr selten zu viel und nichts macht
verdoppelt
sulz
regula schätzt die abendstunden auf dem
hof mit dem sanitäterinnen sohn hat sich
die familie an den großen wunsch erfüllt
was schwimmt traum realisieren mitreden
sollte bewusst betrogen blick
instruments knies
marcel hat noch einen termin
er ist präsident bei den eltern freuden
werten schneien
einmal im monat treffen sich die männer
und picknick stellen und wanderwege in
stand zu halten
auch holz für den grillplatz wird zur
verfügung gestellt
nein
der freiwilligen dieses dauert bis weit
in die nacht
dann beginnt der gesellige teil
morgen stehen sie alle pünktlich wieder
auf und mit ihnen die meisten anderen
menschen in der schweiz jeder mit seinem
alter und mit seiner ganz persönlichen
geschichte nächste woche
sandra dubach behält die übersicht über
den wolken rede am montag schüler zu
zeigen was in ihnen steckt die von wald
bringt neuen schwung in die bülacher
kirchgemeinde und stefano celozzi
sichert die stromproduktion der größten
stadt der schweiz